this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
15,000 classes that could teach you a
new life skill the first 400 people to
sign up using the link in the
description will get a 2 month free
trial since its birth in 1950 the
carriers of the Formula One racing
championship have continually got faster
superior aerodynamics more powerful
engines and lighter materials have all
contributed to make track times plummet
the average speed for the Monaco Grand
Prix rose from a hundred and four
kilometers per hour in 1950 to 170 in
2007 but something strange happened in
2007 they stopped getting faster
not only that they got slower so what
happened and what of the FIA done in
2017 to breed some life back into the
championship again in the past decade
there has been a massive shift and focus
for the f1 championship the skyrocketing
costs of competing forced the FIA to
bring in rules to even the playing field
and prevent better funded teams from
bullying other teams out of the
competition this change in attitude is
earmarked by the 2007 engine development
freeze and the cost-saving measures
continued as Honda BMW and Toyota were
forced to withdraw from the championship
following the 2008 world economic crisis
newer rules have put tyre saving and
fuel efficiency at the forefront of
design which has also forced drivers to
be more conservative on the tracks
forcing the track times down whether
it's because of these changes are not
Formula One's popularity has been
declining and we need to remember that
Formula One is in itself a business a
business that needs to keep both the
companies racing and the fans happy so
this year's rule changes are focused on
making the sport faster and more
dramatic in the hopes of putting a stop
to Formula One's declining popularity so
what changes have been made and how do
they affect the Charis performance the
most noticeable change to this year's
formula 1 cars is the overall width the
width of this year's car has increased
from 1,800 millimetres to 2,000
millimetres with a significant amount of
this additional width been allocated to
facilitating wider tires this
dramatically increases the contact area
of the tyres to the ground which
increases the traction the tire has now
if you look at the equations for
friction you will see it as independent
of area friction is simply given as the
phishing of friction multiplied by the
weight of the carrot so how does a wider
tire increase traction a wider contact
area does affect the wear on the tire
meaning a narrower tire will lose its
grip material quicker to counteract that
the tire needs to be made of a harder
material that won't wear as quickly f1
teams have five dry weather materials to
choose from during the race ranging from
ultra soft to hurt the softer materials
have higher coefficient of frictions but
don't last very long so in essence the
wider tires have allowed the softer
higher grip tires to last longer
allowing drivers to brake later and
accelerate harder these wider tires
needed a wider front wing as its primary
purpose is not to generate downforce but
to manipulate the incoming airflow
around the tires the tires can generate
a great deal of drag and also generate a
huge amount of turbulent air which would
prevent the aerodynamic surfaces
downstream of the tire from working
correctly so the front wing is designed
to direct the air to flow around the
tire one of the most beautiful
applications of this airflow management
is this vortex named the Wai 250 vortex
by f1 rules this central portion of the
wing is not allowed to generate any
downforce about 250 millimeters from the
center you may the vortex is a result of
downforce being generated by the front
wing but instead of just being a
negative side effect that causes drag
the vortices can be carefully crafted to
bend the air away from the tires and to
where it's needed to learn more let's
look at some engineering simulations and
compare the differences between the 2016
and 2017 carries these may look scary to
an untrained eye but here is the gist of
what you need to know here we are
looking at air pressure along the car
with the position being indicated here
blue and green is low-pressure air
yellow and red is higher pressure air an
f1 car wants low-pressure air below the
car and high-pressure air above the car
as that is what generates downforce
let's bring the simulation back to the
start and see how these changes have
affected the performance of the car here
you can see the y 250 vortex beginning
to form as air rolls from the upper
surface of the wing to the lower surface
you can clearly see the y 250 vortex is
larger this year as a result of the
larger wing surface and it gets larger
as it travels down the vehicle as the
low-pressure air
in the surrounding air and the Moreira
consumes the less air can get under the
car fills dropping the air pressure you
can see this happening here as the floor
structure begins you can also see the y
250 vortex begins to generate additional
low-pressure vortices this year off the
barge board which steers the vortices
and helps them generate new low-pressure
vortices like this one being formed off
this neat little airfoil the barge board
was not allowed last year in this
location as the area was an exclusion
zone which is an area where structures
are not allowed to be placed teams like
Mercedes have incredibly intricate barge
boards much more complicated than the
ones in this model traveling further we
can see the 2017 version is noticeably
greener here and thus lower pressure
this combined with the wider floor
allows the 2017 car to generate much
more downforce travelling further again
we find the primary cause of this drop
in pressure the diffuser this part at
the back of the car which is increased
in height and width the diffuser is
essentially an exit nozzle for the air
underneath the car and by having a
larger opening the air exiting from
underneath the car is forced to expand
and accelerate to fill the space this
causes the air pressure to drop even
further as Bernoulli's principle tells
us an increase in velocity of a fluid
corresponds with a decrease in air
pressure the diffuser provides a huge
amount of downforce with very little
drag the same can't be said for the rear
wing which was placed high above the car
in 2016
creating a lot of additional drag the
rear wing has dropped down in 2017
reducing its effect on drag as it's
placed in the air that has already been
affected by the structures upstream this
was an effort to maintain the top speed
of the car as drag has increased
dramatically with the widening of the
car the teams have been provided an
additional five kilograms of fuel to
counteract this also as we are halfway
through the 2017 season we are able to
see the effects these changes have made
on f1 without a doubt we have some of
the best-looking caris f1 have seen in a
long time and they are breaking records
again thanks to the additional traction
provided by the wider wheels and
superior aerodynamics but this
additional speed and corners had to
sacrifice some of the exciting
overtaking action as the wider Kerris
are generating a great deal more dirty
air behind them make
it difficult for following carrots to
get enough downforce in corners so have
these changes made f1 more exciting to
watch I'll leave that for you to decide
many of you ask me what software are
used to animate these videos and how I
learned in today's video I use the
combination of Adobe After Effects and
sim scale I thought myself how to use
both by watching videos online these
days you can teach yourself pretty much
any skill online and Skillshare is a
fantastic place to do it with
professional and understandable classes
that follow a clear learning curve
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
15,000 classes in graphic design
animation web development music
photography video game design and more
unfortunately there are no engineering
simulation classes there yet
but I am working on creating my own for
Skillshare at this very moment a Premium
Membership begins at about $10 a month
for unlimited access to all courses but
the first 500 people to sign up with
this link will get a 2 month free trial
in those 2 months you could easily learn
the skills you need to start a new hobby
or business just like I did with this
channel so ask yourself right now
what skill have you been putting off
learning what project have you been
dreaming of completing but you aren't
sure if you have the skills to do it
why not start right now and sign up the
skill share using the link below you
have nothing to lose and a valuable life
skill to gain as usual thanks for
watching and thank you to my patreon
supporters I just uploaded a new episode
of show makers my podcast with Sam from
Wendover productions with special guests
from the wisecrack channel with a link
to that and the links to my Twitter
Facebook and Instagram pages are below